moving through the aftermath of battle
in what used to be a marketplace now
ammunition shells litter the streets
the situation remains dire for Sudanese
trapped inside a city-turned
Battleground
crisis is Big the situation is very
tough and there's difficulty in internal
movements we often stand in long queues
to get bread it happened many times
where we get bread but never the amount
that my family need
the damage has hit everything both of
them are fighting each other and we the
people will be the biggest losers and
the most affected
where's the two parties to the conflict
namely al-burhan and hamiti to show the
Sudanese people 10 percent only of the
care and attention they gave to foreign
countries through safe corridors to
evacuate their Nationals from the
country we need to take our sick people
to hospitals and to remove the dead
bodies from the streets
Emergency Services have been stretched
Beyond capacity and are pleading for
help a doctor filmed these scenes at the
heartum hospital
there are still injured people in the
hospital medical supply is a very scarce
no medical teams have managed to reach
us due to lack of security and safety on
the roads leading to the hospital they
injured are still coming to hospital
because of the current battles if the
fighting wasn't enough some fear armed
looters even more
CCTV footage captures men dressed in
military fatigues and carrying weapons
breaking into shops it's not clear who
these men are or which side they belong
to both the military and Rapid support
forces accuse each other of breaking Law
and Order
elsewhere in the country the town of
ganina near the border with chat has
seen intense battles
the area has witnessed ethnic conflict
in the recent past now the sound of
gunfire can be heard as locals run for
cover
there are reports the city has no
electricity and very limited phone
connectivity countries continue to
evacuate their people from Sudan Aid
workers arrived in Jordan on Thursday I
think
obviously for Sudanese people behind the
Sudanese Army has denied reports of
possible talks with the rsf it said in a
statement that rapid support forces have
no choice but to surrender or perish I
said Big Al Jazeera
the United Nations secretary